lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en el tipo de preguntas en las
que necesitamos utilizar la estadística
y el tipo de preguntas en las que no
necesitamos utilizar la estadística
podemos llamar a las que necesitan
estadística como preguntas
preguntas estadísticas
preguntas estadísticas circulares
las preguntas estadísticas en amarillo y
te invito a que parece este vídeo e
intente resolver esto primero por ti
mismo mira cada una de estas preguntas y
piensa si necesita la estadística para
resolver esa pregunta o no necesitas la
estadística si estas son preguntas
estadísticas o no
así que asumiendo que ya has pausado el
vídeo ahora podemos abordar esto juntos
la primera pregunta es qué edad tienes
estamos hablando de qué tan mayor es una
persona en particular hay una respuesta
aquí no necesitamos de ninguna
herramienta de la estadística para
resolver esto por lo que esta no es una
pregunta estadística
qué edad tienen las personas que han
visto este vídeo en el 2013 ahora esto
es interesante estamos asumiendo que
diferentes personas han visto este vídeo
en el 2013 y no todas eran de la misma
edad
habrá variabilidad en las edades así que
una persona puede tener 10 años otra
persona 20
otra persona
así que qué responderías aquí darías
todas las edades
pero queremos tener una idea general de
qué edad tienen las personas por lo que
aquí es donde podría ser valiosa la
estadística
quizá queramos encontrar algún tipo de
medida de tendencia central un promedio
la mediana de las edades para esto así
que esta es absolutamente una pregunta
estadística quizá hayan visto ya una
especie de patrón aquí en la primera
pregunta se está preguntando de una
persona en particular sólo hay una
respuesta no hay variabilidad en la
respuesta la segunda pregunta la edad de
un grupo de personas y la variabilidad
en la edad no son de la misma edad todas
se necesita de la estadística para
obtener algunas características del
conjunto de datos para poder hacer
algunas conclusiones podríamos decir en
promedio la gente que vio el vídeo en el
2013 tiene 18 años o 22 años o la
mediana es de 24 años lo que sea más
conveniente
pasemos a la siguiente los perros corren
más rápido que los gatos una vez más hay
muchos perros y muchos gatos y todos
ellos corren a velocidades diferentes
algunos perros corren más rápido que
algunos gatos y algunos gatos corren más
rápido que algunos perros así que
necesitamos un poco de estadística para
darnos una idea de en general o en
promedio qué tan rápido corren los
perros y tal vez en promedio qué tan
rápido corren los gatos y luego podemos
comparar esos promedios o comparar las
medianas de alguna manera
así que esta es definitivamente una
pregunta estadística una vez más estamos
hablando de en general la población
total de perros la especie completa de
perros contra gatos y hay variaciones en
qué tan rápido corren los perros y qué
tan rápido corren los gatos
si estuviéramos hablando de un perro en
particular y de un gato en particular
entonces sólo habría una respuesta corre
el perro más rápido que el gato ve por
supuesto que esa no sería una pregunta
estadística no tienes que utilizar las
herramientas de la estadística
la siguiente pregunta de hecho encaja
con ese patrón los lobos pesan de hecho
no no no está concuerda con el patrón
del anterior
los lobos pesan más que los perros
una vez más hay unos perros muy ligeros
y unos lobos muy pesados así que esos
lobos definitivamente pesan más que esos
perros pero hay unos perros muy muy
pesados así que lo que quieres hacer
aquí ya que tenemos variabilidad en cada
uno de estos es encontrar una tendencia
central un promedio cual es la mediana
del peso del lobo cual es la media del
peso del lobo y comparar eso con la
media del peso del perro por lo que una
vez más al estar hablando del logos en
general y no en un logo en particular y
en general sobre los perros y estamos
intentando y hay variaciones en los
datos y estamos intentando obtener
algunos números de eso para comparar
esta es definitivamente una pregunta
estadística definitivamente una pregunta
estadística
tu perro pesa más que es el lobo y
estamos asumiendo que estamos señalando
un lobo en particular ahora esto es
particular estamos comparando un perro
un perro en particular con un lobo en
particular podemos poner a cada uno en
una báscula y obtener una respuesta
absoluta no hay variabilidad en el peso
de este perro por lo menos en el momento
en el que lo estamos pensando y no hay
variabilidad en el peso de este lobo en
el momento en el que lo estamos pensando
así que esta no es una pregunta
estadística pondré una equis al lado de
las que no son preguntas estadísticas
llueve más centrado que en singapur así
que una vez más hay variación aquí y
nosotros probablemente también queramos
notar que hubo más lluvia en seattle en
singapur en un determinado año o durante
una década y a pesar de esas preguntas
aunque las preguntemos para algunos años
podría llover más encierro y en otros
años podría llover más en singapur o si
solo escogiera mostrado yo vería una
cantidad distinta de año a año en
singapur llueve una cantidad diferente
año con año así que como comparamos ahí
es donde la estadística puede ser
valiosa
hay variabilidad en los datos por lo que
podemos ver el conjunto de datos
deseados y obtener un tipo de promedio
un tipo de tendencia central y comparar
eso con el promedio la media la moda lo
que se quizá la moda sea la más útil
aquí de singapur por lo que esta es
definitivamente definitivamente una
pregunta estadística definitivamente
estadística
cuál fue la diferencia en precipitación
entre singapur y sea 2 en el 2013 bueno
estos dos números son conocidos pueden
ser medidos ambos la precipitación en
singapur puede medirse y la
precipitación en siador puede medirse y
asumiendo que esto ya ha pasado y que
podemos medirlo entonces podemos
encontrar la diferencia no necesitas la
estadística aquí solo necesitamos tener
ambas mediciones y sustraer las para
obtener la diferencia así que no es una
pregunta estadística en general
utilizaré menos gasolina manejando a 55
millas por hora que a 70 millas por hora
esto parece ser estadístico porque
probablemente depende de las
circunstancias puede depender del coche
o incluso para un auto dado cuando
manejas a 55 millas por hora
hay algo de variación en tu rendimiento
de gasolina puede deberse
qué tan reciente se le cambió el aceite
las condiciones de viento las
condiciones del camino cómo estás
manejando el auto
estás en una curva vas por una línea
recta y sucede lo mismo para 70 millas
por hora
ya que esto es general hay variación en
el rendimiento de gasolina a 55 millas
por hora y a 70 millas por hora lo que
probablemente quieras hacer es saber
cuál es mi rendimiento promedio de
gasolina cuando manejo a 55 millas por
hora y comparar eso con el rendimiento
promedio de gasolina cuando manejo a 70
y debido a que tenemos esa variabilidad
en cualquiera de los dos casos esta es
definitivamente definitivamente una
pregunta estadística
los profesores de inglés tienen un
sueldo menor que los profesores de
matemáticas una vez más no todos los
profesores de inglés tienen el mismo
sueldo y no todos los profesores de
matemáticas tienen el mismo sueldo
algunos profesores de inglés puede irles
muy bien otros pueden ganar muy poco y
pasa lo mismo para los profesores de
matemáticas
probablemente queramos encontrar algún
tipo de promedio para representar la
tendencia central para cada uno de estos
por lo que una vez más esta es una
pregunta estadística está
una pregunta
estadística
el profesor de inglés con mejor sueldo
de harvard tiene un sueldo mayor que el
profesor de matemáticas con mayor sueldo
del emat y bueno ahora estamos hablando
de dos individuos en particular puedes
ir a ver sus recibos de pago pero cuánto
recibe cada uno y especialmente si
asumimos que este es un año en
particular
digamos hagámoslo de esta manera
en él
solo para quitar cualquier tipo de
variabilidad que pueda presentarse año
con año solo para hacerlo un poco más
concreto
así que queda el profesor de inglés con
mejor sueldo de harvard tiene un sueldo
mayor que el profesor de matemáticas con
mayor sueldo de el maitén en el 2013
entonces tienes un número absoluto para
cada una cada una de estas personas y
puedes sólo compararlas directamente y
como estamos hablando de un año en
particular de gente en particular
entonces esta no es una pregunta
estadística